تفاصيل اكثر عن معركه بخموت واهميتها
لطرفين نتابعها مع محمود وبالمناسبه بخموت
تعني محمود كما يبدو ايضا نعم بالفعل
عثمان بخ مت هي ربما تعود الى شخص من
التتار المسلمين الذين اقاموا هناك خلال
الدوله العثمانيه وكان اسمه محمود وطبعا
تحريف الاسم بحسب اللغه الاوكرانيه
هذا ليس سبب اختيارك لان كنت في اوكرانيا
وملم ايضا تطلعني على تفاصيل اكثر محمود
اتفضل نتابع اكثر اذا هذا الاسم اسم باخمت
اصبح واحدا من اكثر الاسماء تكرارا في حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا يعود ذلك طبعا الى ان
معركه السيطره عليها هي اطول المعارك في
الحرب بمده ناهزت تقريبا سبعه اشهر فضلا
عن دمويه هذه المعركه اذ يقتل في محيطها
يوميا مئات الجنود من الطرفين وفقا
للتقارير اخر التطورات فيها هو اعلان
ميليشيا باجنر سيطرتها على كامل الجزء
الشرقي هنا من باخمت نتحدث عن هذا الجزء
شرق نهر هذه السيطره اعقبت معارك عنيفه في
الاسابيع الماضيه شهدت هجمات طبعا هذه
المعارك شهدت هجمات جويه كثيره
بعضها
بالقصف وبعضها ايضا محاولات اقتحام بريه
من هنا كما نتابع وانتهت طبعا الى اعلان
القوات الروسيه سيطرتها الناريه على كامل
الطرق المؤديه الى المدينه بمعنى ان جميع
هذه الطرق كما نشاهد هنا مثل هذا الطريق
الذي يؤدي الى بخموت اصبحت تحت يشملها
القصف بالمدفعيه براجمات الصواريخ
وبالتالي يحد من وصول الامدادات اليها
ويتيح مساحه اكبر للقوات الروسيه للاقتحام
السؤال الاكثر الحاحا الان هو ماذا لو
سقطت باخمت ما اهميه هذه المدينه قد
تساعدنا طبعا صوره اوسع على تصور اوضح
تقول القوات الاوكرانيه انها نقلت كثيرا
من دفاعاتها التي كانت موجوده هنا في
بخموت نحن الان مع صوره اوسع كما تشاهدون
الى هنا في الخلف طبعا حضر الرئيس الينسكي
كما سمعتم من ان سقوط باخمت قد يعني سقوط
مدن اخرى في مثل
لكن بالتالي نتحدث هنا طبعا اذا سقطت هذه
المدن عن سقوط دنيا وبالتالي كامل لكن كما
نلاحظ هنا لا تقع باخموت على طرق الامداد
لاي من هذه المدن التي تقع شرقا وهي طبعا
متصله هذه المدن كما نشاهدها وهي متصله
بكامل
الارض واوكرانيا من كل الجهات بالتالي
نستطيع القول ان الاهميه الكبرى
المدينه هي الاهميه
الرمزيه كما ذكرنا سابقا وانها ستكون طبعا
السيطره الاولى لروسيا منذ اشهر خسرت فيها
الكثير من المناطق في خيرسون وحول خاركيف
ايضا هذه المناطق التي ترونها باللون
الرمادي هنا وهي بحاجه لاينصر رمزي طبعا
روسيا وقد يكون هذا ايضا سبب الاصرار
الاوكراني على التمسك بالمدينه بعد سلسله
من الانتصارات الاخيره خلال الاشهر
الماضيه اذا هو نصر الرمزي او هزيمه
الرمزيه